laronne and welcome to another TV basics
tutorial video in this video I'm gonna
be showing you guys how we can get saved
from our paint screen back to our main
screen so before it was really easy
because we had just gigantic buttons but
now I want to actually impose another
button on this screen maybe a button
here that you know says go back home
okay and it looks better than that
hopefully and we can click that and
actually go back home so that's our goal
and so that's what we're going to be
doing in this video so anyways let's go
ahead get started so we don't actually
have to change really anything here you
might notice that I've changed lost my
mouse okay
I've changed this to main 3 now because
it's another video for me but you might
be following along in the same file the
whole time so uh here is my main 3
script and now to add a button we
actually don't really need to touch
anything more in here so I'm just going
to come down here and within another
screen we have painter and now what we
can do though is we can also see the
painter is basically just a widget okay
so we load in painter and then we'll
load in a button easy enough
this buttons gonna have a bunch of
parameters so the first parameter will
be let's say color the color of the
button zero one zero one for lovely
green font size will say 25 size hints
this is basically just the size of the
button according to the size of the page
so 0.3 and 0.2 then we're gonna add some
text on this button the text is gonna
say back home and then we're gonna say
on underscore release and on release
what do we want to do basically the same
thing as this button so I'm just
actually I copy and paste and instead of
other we want to go back to main so you
might remember this from a couple videos
ago and then
we're going to position this using posts
hint
in fact I forgot to add our float layout
dirt anyway post hints and we'll add
this in four right whoops : 1 and then
top : 1 add your quotes here picture
spacing issues ok now what we also want
to do is our button is just a widget or
well okay the painter is just a widget
and so sort of is the button but we're
going to come down here and now we're
going to reference a floats layouts :
and then within float layout we're gonna
put the painter and the button the
painter widget enter button so let's go
ahead and save that now and let's run
that see how we do next screen now we've
got our paint we'll just paint high and
then we can click back home we head back
home and go back to next screen our
stuffs even still there fancy fancy
fancy okay well that's basically it for
adding the button to this screen just
wanted to show a real simple example of
how to do it sometimes people ask me to
give them some challenges so I will give
you a challenge and that will be now to
add a Clear button to the screen and
there's even some code online as far as
how to do the clear you can go to the TV
website they actually have a paint
application and they have a clear button
there you probably won't be able to
superimpose that clear button really
simply but there is a way to do it so I
encourage you to try to do it if you can
figure it out please try to post or
please post it here and share with the
others if you figure out a good way to
do it so anyways that's it for this
video
if you guys have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching things for all this board's
subscriptions and until next time